he's not answering any question that's
okay I have no questions that's right
I'm about to the monologues son I better
make it quick you only got eight minutes
all right then let me paint you a
picture I'm Phillip a successful
periodontist that's become addicted to
diazepam
I said it if I take because I'm junkie
scum also for real addiction is a
disease that would be super empathetic
if you had murder demand what is the
point of this I'll get there so one day
I'm working late when my boss Robert
surprises me he found out I was stealing
meds again
Chucky's gum also again not your fault
there's a major genetic component to
addiction he says he's gonna file a
police report I could lose my license we
fight and something in me just snapped
so I grabbed the first thing I can find
and I hit him with it you still have no
murder weapon I do now here's a pic I
found on Yelp of the surgical suite six
months ago and here's a shot that our
crime scene photographer took up the
same room two weeks after the murder
notice any differences we don't
answering that that's all right I can
just tell you myself the Yelp shot has
six of these heavy-looking glass Awards
from the Brooklyn periodontics society
in the background whereas this shot only
has five what happened to number six
murdered Robert with them you lost all
control and you bludgeoned him to death
there must have been blood everywhere
but you got lucky you were in the
surgical suite it can be sterilized you
never would have gotten away with it in
your carpeted office that's no what
happened to anything more fun and your
office manager would have heard all of
the screaming but she was at her
grandson's play lucky again you're wrong
you put Roberts body into a wheelchair
shoved it in the elevator it's a miracle
there wasn't blood everywhere that's not
true now you're in the garage with a
corpse you panicked and left your phone
in your office and you don't have your
car keys but Roberts are in his pocket
so you put him in his car and you take
off you can't believe what you've done
no Phillip you're flustered you have no
GPS so you just start driving oh yeah
well next thing you know you're in the
pine barrens and it hits you your
uncle's cabin he has a place there
you're the luckiest son of one luck yes
it was you got lucky at every turn no I
knew exactly where I was driving I left
my phone in the office on purpose I was
in a surgical suite by design and I
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see what's missing I
made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it then melted
it back down it's already in the
patient's mouth son oh damn oh damn
Oh
you